hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander sally so we're gonna check
out kingbach vines that's his name came
back king batch rocks buck my bad I
don't know I don't know how miners it's
a compilation that was sent to me two
thousand fourteen hundred eighty vines
180 plus vines
this is what selling I do we put in the
hard work of watching a video for you
the airport I was already headed there
was nice
get my [ __ ] in pairs and they go and
gorillas you're my partner
oh crap one thing that guys wedding
doesn't let you call yeah right boy
crash dummy wait what yo bats what you
doing man
yeah you want them going on Oh
Tuesday got you girl what are you
supposed to be we gonna kick back start
Julie uh let's run it yourself okay
[ __ ]
you just I got you
why [ __ ] cuz I'm black yeah music hold
up hold onto any backup right away oh
gosh [ __ ] quiet down DJ and when you
come back
one week ago you'd be tweaking up oh
yeah this is where it is amazing the
mood and go beat we've all a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ]
first thanks for a summer release
religiously now or filling
no no yes good you got my soul Jane copy
I'll call you anything no you ain't
calling [ __ ] like that right right [ __ ]
face - take this [ __ ] named Tammy
screw your belly the names Oh what is
that thing it's pesticide I'm gonna call
it pest to be no you want to be my date
go without me
hey George don't even wonder story one
if they don't wink which by Michael
Westen catching me losing favor suffice
page
hey guys what's up [ __ ] as soon but
Cap'n Crunch yeah yeah yeah say cheese
oh oh what the [ __ ] bro
tonight oh you make me happy when Kenny
G boy back ain't mama be on instagram at
King match I practice what I preach I'm
gonna cook two miles pray what they eat
think of us rewrite this [ __ ] right now
I know you let me get four large
speeches of million hot wings and
family-size pasta and give me something
get this make a couple bites that day
fictional Pompey got that gas one Pedro
here I get a [ __ ] leg back short two
inches no you know what they do each
other with the man right here uh King
back [ __ ] you you make I'm a music paper
with PVD snake a picking his spots
yeah hello Tex make it come hop in
yourself
domains great what the hell you wearing
right we change yeah I not know words I
got know what I guess woody we're on a
plane you not good you said make
yourself oh yes [ __ ]
over there don't worry gave me a pony
right yes well you got my name is big
are you automatically connect to Wi-Fi
[ __ ] baby before
yeah [ __ ] last Tuesday where are you
friend AJ's gonna get those key I know
what is wrong talk to me Oh
first leg pick it up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] know me yeah cool
so what you guys what I smash Sophie
tada what did you find me is that 2000
receipts a 2019 so the money so
respectful [ __ ] - mascius up I got 99
problems but a [ __ ] eat me
what are you doing what a black man can
have a TV you can be black cavity and I
put these masks old
yah-yah-yah talk to you later bye bye
[ __ ]
hey you gotta squint your eyes invite
your mom and get your number
hey I said hey your mom let me get your
number this video get back welcome to
kill my best pal like it like that song
actually xenos in a panic up and they go
to bed
touchdown [ __ ] gimme more than a Jimmy
first let me drink it tell me ready or
not I got you turn down good luck Hey
in China kiss me right here and dirty
wake up piggy you I knew I knew [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay keep each other y'all these
ladies man what do you think it is Oh
daddy
Hayley's for a bottle of lotion a day
you can help these ashy african-american
children please
happy Valentine's Day would you get me
oh you get the roses oh let me send them
again hey you ready to wall up there
like okay
we always fancies we better win we got
away luckily your father by your back do
something - you say whoa whoa hey guys
what's up jeez - that's good and it's
guys brilliant yeah I'm not vine
familiar at all that's why I never use
ours but that is you know watching these
like vines is pretty inspiring you know
to see like what you can come up with in
six seconds like the perfect joke in six
seconds you know like he's got it down
you knows how to establish a set up and
then deliver that punchline and he the
time frame is just perfect on this guy
it's funny as hell
that's why stuff like popular so famous
no no she knows a lot of famous people -
you sounded so cool yeah you know what
we're gonna start making vines yeah yeah
when you start doing some bombs the real
rejects mine at the room rigid mm-hmm
yeah she have your own vine - I do it's
done I'll Monaco and there's two of them
for some reason but the one that I use
is my profile picture that is black and
white so anyway no that was cool I'm
glad you guys introduce me to who this
dude was I'm gonna so yeah I want a
grape vines this guy really inspired me
for sure yeah we keep a lookout for that
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects sally
has a channel check that [ __ ] out -
salamander Sally
do you follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where we're trying to get
product placement by getting a certain
amount of followers so yeah
product placement I want french fry
companies to sponsor me fries are great
they're tasty they're hot
and um their Gracie
let's face it some woman like greasy
like Sally she shoves them up there in
the B hi hole no sorry I realized that
people are now expecting a type of
sexual reference when it comes to the
product and you say greasy and that was
the best I could come up with was your
greasy butthole with a fry
that is the word to describe yes your